EU ministers of finance will start their
talks with a general discussion on the
economic situation in the European Union
they will also take stock of work on
flexibility under the EU stability and
growth pact and financial assistance to
Romania ministers will also examine
ongoing work on the proposed European
fund for strategic investments which is
one of the core elements of the
Commission's 315 billion euros
investment plan for Europe the aim is to
reach a final agreement by June to
enable cash to start flowing by mid-2015
the fund will support job creating
projects in areas such as transport
energy and broadband infrastructure
education research and innovation
ministers will also discuss in-depth
reviews of the macroeconomic imbalances
in 16 Member States published by the
Commission in March these yearly reviews
aim at helping countries prevent &
correct their macroeconomic imbalances
and to create conditions for sustainable
growth in the European Union the council
will also take a look at the
implementation of its 2014 country
specific recommendations on economic
employment and fiscal policies under the
European semester the e u--'s annual
policy monitoring process finally
ministers will look at the projections
for age-related expenditure in pensions
health care or unemployment benefits in
the 28 member states until 2060 they
will also discuss the results of the
last g20 finance meeting in Washington
in April